[Musique]
bienvenue sur tv soixante dix huit pour
ce rendez vous spécial à quelques jours
du premier tour de l'élection municipale
partielle à trappes le 10 octobre les
électeurs elles seront appelés aux urnes
une nouvelle fois après l'annulation du
scrutin de 2020 et pour aider les
habitants à faire leur choix nous vous
proposons aujourd'hui un débat entre les
candidats quatre listes se présentent
lutte ouvrière fait entendre le camp des
travailleurs menée par patrick planque
l'union à républicaine pour travaux
menés par othman nassr ou trappe à
gauche menée par luc miserait et puis la
gauche unie pour que tu rappes respire
la liste du maire sortant ali rabais
dont l'élection a donc été invalidée par
le conseil d'état nous avons eu
l'occasion d'en parler à sur cette
antenne à lire avec il n'est pas en
plateau nous l'avions conviés à venir
échanger avec othman masse roues mais il
ne souhaitait pas participer à un débat
avec je cite un opposant qui le dit
femme gravement il laisse je cite
toujours au trappistes le soin
d'arbitrer les désaccords dans les urnes
entre manas où vous aurez l'occasion si
vous le souhaitez à d'y répondre avant
de commencer ce débat cette émission se
déroulant en direct ce 7 octobre les
temps de parole des candidats présents
seront donc chronométrés afin de
respecter au mieux à la règle de
l'égalité bonjour à vous trois messieurs
et bienvenue en plateau bonjour la
première prise de parole se fera dans
l'ordre d'enregistrement de vos
candidatures en préfecture on va donc
débuter avec vous patrick planque lors
du scrutin de 2000 20 au second tour le
taux de participation n'était que de 38
25% à
5155 électeurs s'étaient déplacés
que dites-vous aux 7 fonctionne east ce
soir alors c'est vrai que ces élections
elles vont se passer dans un contexte un
peu difficile
à la fois parce que les attaques contre
le monde du travail elles sont elle se
sauve augmente les attaques contre les
allocations chômage aussi est il ya
toute une partie de la population qui ne
va pas aller voter comme les précédentes
les précédentes élections parce que
les n'y croit plus parce que les
promesses qu'on peut leur faire les uns
et les autres pour
soi-disant améliorer le sort des
travailleurs le sort de la population on
voit bien les différents gouvernements
qui se sont succédé depuis 20 ans depuis
trente ans la situation s'est aggravée
et c'est aussi pour ça que nous on
présente une liste sans promesse
uniquement constitué travailleurs qui
défend un point de vue de lutte en
disant oui il va falloir s'organiser il
va falloir se défendre il va face se
bagarrer dans ses dents dans ces
élections et après contre le patronat
contre le gouvernement qui prépare les
mauvais coups même question à vous
autres magnats through d'élections en
élections la participation chute et pas
uniquement à trappes d'ailleurs au delà
des grandes déclarations qui ont eu lieu
encore la dernière fois après les
élections régionales que dire aux
électeurs pour les mobiliser qui plus
est sur une élection qui a lieu en
dehors des clous habitué à l'élection
partielle mais moi je veux vous
remercier d'avoir votre invitation vous
remercier de nous donner l'occasion d'un
débat de fond quelles que soient les
divergences mais d'un débat respectueux
d'un débat sur des problématiques qui
concernent le quotidien des trappistes
et on ne peut pas à la fois déploré
l'absence de participation des électeurs
au scrutin et ne pas participer à ce
débat et je regrette aussi la tonalité
de cette campagne qui effectivement est
une campagne qui touche maintenant à sa
fin qui était une campagne très
agressive il faut que chacun prenne la
responsabilité de l'apaisement et encore
une fois pour revenir à des sujets de
fond il ya beaucoup de choses à dire et
beaucoup de choses à faire moi j'espère
que les trappistes vont se mobiliser de
manière importante dimanche peut-être
pas aussi importante que pour un scrutin
normal mais j'espère que néanmoins la
participation sera au rendez vous parce
que cela va venir décider de la manière
dont la ville va être gérée pour les
cinq prochaines années et je crois que
dans les cinq prochaines années nous
aurons besoin vraiment d'une gestion
apaisée d'une gestion rassembleuse d'une
gestion responsable avec un projet clair
et au delà des clivages qui nous divise
et qui nous affaiblissent beaucoup on le
voit dans la tonalité générale de cette
campagne bon je suis convaincu que les
trappistes ils attendent autre chose que
simplement des invectives ou des
histoires d'étiquette politique qu'ils
attendent des choses concrètes pour eux
ça ne veut pas dire qu'on peut tout
faire du jour au lendemain mais je crois
que la ville depuis un an a pris une
mauvaise direction et je crois que dans
les cinq prochaines années nous avons
des dossiers importants à régler
luc miserait pour la liste trappe à
gauche même chose votre sentiment et
puis j'ajouterai peut-être aussi
peut-être votre sentiment au regarde de
l'image que tu rappes véhicules ces
dernières mois et ces dernières années
même j'élargis
las de cette dernière année ces
dernières années il ya toujours une
image très négative de cette ville de
trappes il ya donc forcément des
attentes des habitants pour redorer un
petit peu l'image et agir au quotidien
et pourtant ils se mobilisent pas
toujours
effectivement le ya pas que l'image
qu'ils de la ville qui a été écornée
parce que si avec l'image
ce sera encore pas trop grave mais c'est
les conséquences que ça sur la vie des
trappistes et sur le développement de
trappes il ya beaucoup de effectivement
de désespérance patrick lang a rappelé
tout à l'heure beaucoup de dégoût aussi
d'une
d'une campagne assez délétère qui s'est
cristallisé autour
d'un débat
entre
monsieur n'à through monsieurr avait
alors que les problématiques des
trappistes sont au delà donc nous on
essaye de travailler de manière plus
sereine et de dire que tout ça ça suffit
que pendant que ces polémiques
s'entretiennent eh bien on parle pas des
réels problèmes et des réel enjeu pour
les trappistes aujourd'hui est ce que
vous pensez concrètement quel que soit
le prochain maire que au cours de son
mandat il va pouvoir rapidement changer
les choses on a l'impression que le
chantier est tellement vaste je voulais
sa parole utiliserait vous avez un peu
plus de retard sur le temps de parole
alors le chantier est vaste et et nord
n'a suffira donc le mandat ne suffira
pas bien évidemment de toute façon le
temps politique est un temps qui
s'inscrit dans la durée mais on peut
tout à la fois avoir des mesures
concrètes rapides
et travailler sur des objectifs à très
court court moyen et long terme donc ça
ça peut se mener de manière et il faut
que ça semaine parce qu'il ya beaucoup
d'attentes de la part de nos concitoyens
vous souhaitez réagir mais dans les
autres alizée patrick pense qu'il n'y a
pas deux il n'y a pas de solution
miracle on n'arrivera pas à régler le
problème du chômage le problème du
logement on aura l'occasion d'en
discuter le problème de la délinquance
etc tous les problèmes qui se posent
dans l'est dans des grandes villes
aujourd'hui
parce que de toute façon l'ensemble de
la société est en crise aujourd'hui est
que c'est une réponse globale qu'il
faudra qu'il faudra apporter avec une
mobilisation des travailleurs des
locataires pour les logements etc et on
n'arrivera pas à régler à créer un îlot
de bien-être de plein emploi au milieu
de dunes d'une catastrophe ambiante
comme comme on la vit aujourd'hui
un sujet particulier je pense
aujourd'hui dans notre municipalité dans
notre ville c'est la manière dont on
veut que la municipalité fonctionne et
en disant cela puisqu'on nous demander
comment on peut avoir des résultats
rapides je veux avoir une pensée pour
nos agents municipaux qui souffrent
beaucoup qui ont vécu d un climat qu'il
n'aurait jamais dû subir depuis depuis
un an et je pense que les re motiver les
impliquer les responsabiliser c'est une
des manières d'obtenir des résultats
concrets on voit par exemple que la
propreté de la ville s'est beaucoup
dégradée cette année et on peut le
comprendre quand on sait la manière dont
sont traités nos agents municipaux et
donc je veux leur adresser cette pensée
et puis simplement parce que ça illustre
qu'une ville ne peut pas être dirigée
contre les agents contre les habitants
contre tous ceux qui ne pensent pas
comme vous on a besoin je les dis
d'apaisement de rassemblement et de
projets et de fond et tout cela on va en
parler de nombreux dossiers pourraient
nous interne nous intéressait concernant
trappe au cours de la prochaine demi
heure on a retenu deux thématiques pour
ce débat le logement cadre de vie et
puis la sécurité aussi on va commencer
avec le logement si les temps de paroles
peuvent juste ça fichiers que les
téléspectateurs puissent voir où vous en
êtes les uns et les autres lui qui
miserait c'est vous qui est le plus en
retard et donc vous allez débuter sur
cette thématique le taux de logements
sociaux sur la commune et de plus de 60%
c'est l'un des plus élevés des yvelines
lé conflit avec les bailleurs aussi sont
nombreux l'insalubrité est bien réel
pendant cette campagne de nombreux
articles s'en sont encore fait l'écho à
travers la presse même nationale déjà
quel constat faites-vous sur le terrain
et puis quelles solutions proposez-vous
le cnid ray
alors le logement est un sujet très
épineux sur la ville d'abord ce que je
voudrais dire c'est que trop souvent le
logement social est un petit peu
montrées du doigt comme si c'était la
cause des problèmes les problèmes ce
sont les conditions de vie des gens qui
sont dans les logements sociaux c'est
pas les logements sociaux le logement
social c'est fait pour que chacun c'est
un droit qui est dans la constitution
française et la possibilité de vivre
dans la dignité dans un logement
correct répondant à ses besoins et c'est
loin d'être le 4 c'est loin d'être le
cas pour les personnes âgées qui
habitent dans des étages où il n'y a pas
d'ascenseur c'est loin d'être le cas
pour les personnes en situation de
handicap qui sont dans les mêmes
conditions c'est loin d'être le cas pour
les personnes isolées et c'est loin
d'être le cas pour des personnes qui
vivent dans des logements en
surpopulation c'est à dire que les
familles qui peuvent être nombreuses
sont dans un f3 et n'arrive pas à avoir
un f4 et c'est donc il ya un effort
énorme affaire à ce niveau là ensuite il
ya ce que vous avez dit au sujet de
du coût du loyer
il y à quelques décennies maintenant les
gens venaient à trappes parce que c'est
à trappes qu'ils avaient les logements
sociaux les moins chers aujourd'hui ce
n'est plus le cas
donc les logements ont augmenté de
manière inconsidérée
les charges de manière opaque de même
manière et donc ça c'est de véritables
problèmes donc nous on pense que la
municipalité tout seul ne va pas pouvoir
résoudre tout cela le bailleur social a
fortiori avec l'action de monsieur
macron qui a cherché à regrouper les
bailleurs sociaux donc à éloigner une
fois de plus le pouvoir de décision du
de l'habitant lambda on sait très bien
qu'à chaque fois qu'on éloigne le
pouvoir de décision à chaque fois c'est
plus de problèmes donc on a besoin de
réunir tout le monde autour de la table
le bailleur social se sont trop forts et
à ce moment là on a besoin des services
de l'état on a besoin de la région on a
besoin du départ on a besoin de tout le
monde pour faire réellement pression
monsieur n'à seront réellement pression
pour que les gens soient considérés de
manière honnête
dernier point que je voulais rajouter
pour nous le logement c'est aussi le
quartier c'est à dire que nous on veut
on a des propositions très concrètes sur
la revitalisation des quartiers les
fautes de la présence humaine dans les
quartiers des services des associations
qui s'impliquent et également de
l'économie sociale et solidaire
aujourd'hui les habitants ont le
sentiment d'être abandonnés très
clairement sur le tout vous êtes sur le
terrain beaucoup plus que nous vous
annonçons aujourd'hui aujourd'hui le
quartier c'est l'endroit où on se
retrouve en famille on vient dormir le
quartier s'est pas simplement ça le
quartier c'est un lieu de vie et donc
qu'il faut revivifier tout cela patrick
planque à présent sur ce sujet du
logement votre constat et et vos
propositions comment faire pression sur
ces bailleurs sociaux justement alors
déjà c'est vrai que le constat il est il
y as alarmant j'ai pas si vous avez vu
les publications récentes la qui donne
le chiffre de 4 millions de mal logés en
france qui est paru aujourd'hui
ce qui est complètement délirant c'est
la quantité de logements vides le fait
que à la fois les bailleurs sociaux sont
un freak éhontés sur en augmentant les
charges en augmentant les loyers etc et
puis il ya toute la politique des
promoteurs parce que il faut pas les
oublier tous ces fabricants de béton qui
quand même préfère fabriquer des dés
des centres commerciaux ou des des
bureaux quitte à les laisser vide ça
c'est une vraie c'est une vraie
politique
contre la population contre les
travailleurs contre les salariés contre
les les habitants etc alors oui il
faudrait renouer avec avec des luttes et
- au-delà de au delà de discuter avec
les bailleurs je pense qu'il faut que
les travailleurs les les locataires ils
s'organisent s'est pas uniquement un
problème d'association c'est pas un
problème uniquement de dire on va faire
appel à la mairie pour pour faire
pression sur le bailleur parce que ça ne
suffira pas et ça ne marche pas on l'a
bien vu
ça ne marche pas c'est pas ça la
solution la seule solution qui
fonctionne un peu c'est comme dans les
entreprises quand les travailleurs quand
les locataires s'empare des choses
s'empare des dossiers est réellement
font pression et puis et s'il y avait
des élus lutte ouvrière à la
municipalité bien évidemment il se
ferait le relais de tout c'est de toutes
ces luttes parce que quand on voit
certains quartiers qui sont restés
l'année dernière tout l'hiver sans
chauffage jusqu'à ce que les mots clés
des locataires se mobilisent bien
évidemment il faudrait appuyer et des
élus communistes révolutionnaires comme
comme on aime il proposerait en tout cas
d'organiser d'un d'apporter leur soutien
à ces luttes de locataires dans les
quartiers votre mana soit vous êtes
aussi élu à la région ile de france
c'est pour ça que l'udc miserait tout à
leur disait appuyé collectivement
concrètement la région est ce qu'elle
intervient concrètement si vous vous
êtes maire de trappes demain comment
vous allez travailler avec la région
avec le département avec l'agglomération
puisque cela bien entendu il faut les
habitants se mobilisent et il faut que
tous les différents services toutes les
collectivités travaillent ensemble
d'abord je suis heureux qu'on discute de
ce thème parce qu'il est désormais
installé dans le débat local ça n'a pas
toujours été le cas pendant des années
et j'ai eu le sentiment d'être le seul à
avoir dit qu'il y avait un sujet avec un
certain nombre de bailleurs sociaux à
trappes qui se comporte d'une manière
que je qualifie mois d' indigne je me
souviendrai toujours 2013 quand l'eau
courante a été coupée à thorez pendant
quatre jours j'étais là et je m'en
souviendrai toujours pas ce que j'ai vu
comment on pouvait aussi ne pas traiter
avec le respect des locataires qui à
partir du moment où ils payent leur
loyer ont le droit à un an logement
digne décent et bien sûr bien entretenu
il ya des charges qu'ils soient
maîtrisés et donc je remercie et luc
misery de m'avoir reconnu d'avoir essayé
de mettre la pression sans être aux
responsabilités
j'ai entendu mettre la pression
réellement mais pour être mettre la
pression réellement il faut en avoir les
outils juridiques il se trouve que la
salubrité est une compétence municipale
et on va pas parler de monsieur raz b
puisqu'il a choisi de ne pas venir
débattre il a eu en charge ce sujet un
moment dans de ce mandat la seule
question qui se pose c'est est ce que
aujourd'hui on fait le nécessaire face
aux bailleurs sociaux moi je souhaite
faire plusieurs choses je les ai déjà
dit j'ai proposé une cellule d'aidé
juridique posé pendant des années durant
mon mandat d'opposition précédent pour
que les locataires soient aidés dans
leurs démarches j'ai proposé que la
mairie aide contrôle des charges on
découvre souvent des charges excessives
et donc je le dis très clairement si les
trappistes nous font confiance comme je
le souhaite et comme je l'espère est
bien là nous dirons tout simplement
bailleurs que la partie est finie et que
désormais la municipalité contrôlera la
municipalité mettra en demeure la
municipalité aidera au contrôle des
charges la municipalité ne travaillera
plus avec les bailleurs dont on
considère qu'ils entretiennent pas
suffisamment leurs parcs regarder l'état
aujourd'hui de l'allée des yvelines
au moment où je vous parle vous irez au
6 rue victor jara à camus pour voir
qu'il ya encore sept familles en attente
de relogement dans des conditions
inacceptables inacceptables un travail
important a été fait par guy malandain
pendant des années chaque tour on lui
reconnaît sur la rénovation urbaine de
trappes la ville a changé de visage il
faut maintenant qu'on poursuive ensemble
ce travail et qu'on donne un cadre de
vie décent à tous les trappistes évident
à vis des bailleurs je le dis c'était un
combat qui me tient à coeur à titre
personnel et je ferai le nécessaire pour
qu'ils tiennent leurs obligations en
matière d'entretien et en matière des
charges il ne s'agit ici que du respect
de la loi il n'y a pas de raison que
cette loi ne s'applique pas aussi à
trappes
oui je peux pas laisser mme yonath roux
s'arroger le monopole de la lutte pour
le logement sur ce tracé d'abord le
combat des locataires exactement donc on
a entièrement d'accord conclu l'entente
qui lui j'ai dit le seul élu on est
entièrement d'accord sur le fait que
[Musique]
ce qu'il faut privilégier c'est
effectivement les associations de
locataires c'est elle qu'il faut appuyer
et mettre en oeuvre et ne pas se
substituer mais il faut en même temps
jouer tout son rôle c'est ce que je
disais tout à l'heure est ce que je
voudrais dire quand même c'est que la
région monsieur n'à through qui est la
région la plus riche d'europe
gagnerait en crédibilité à investir
beaucoup plus que ce qu'elle ne fait
dans le logement social dans sa
rénovation dans l'augmentation puisqu'on
sait très bien qu'on a plusieurs
milliers de demandes à trappes qui sont
insatisfaites alors on imagine à
l'échelle de la région ce que ça
représente et c'est pas des demandes
injustifiées cc des demandes qui sont
totalement justifiées et donc on a
besoin d'un investissement beaucoup plus
important il suffit pas faire venir
monsieur apparu ou le vice président
chargé du logement à la région il ya des
possibilités d'intervention
je vous ai entendu dire que vous aviez
copier couper certaines subventions à
valori valophis sari pas parce qu'ils
avaient
pas rempli leur rôle l'objet il n'est
pas de leur couper des subventions
l'objet il est de faire en sorte qu'ils
respectent les gens et donc il faut
faire beaucoup plus que cela et je
miserais votre temps de parole mais je
voulais signer votre phrase tout de même
mais on est arrivé presque à 6 minutes
vous prenez de l'avancé cet engagement
doit être beaucoup plus conséquents me
semble-t-il madness rouge vous laisse
répondre et puis ensuite patrick l'anc
encore une fois on a besoin de l'échelon
municipal pour que cet engagement
fonctionne c'est ce qui manque
aujourd'hui pour dire des choses très
clairement regard des compétences vont
parler d'investissements là dessus les
partenaires de la ville justement besoin
de pouvoir bien travailler que la
municipalité ça n'est plus le cas depuis
un an je vous donne des exemples la
rénovation de jules védrines qui la
finançait le département pour un million
d'euros la rénovation de pergaud qu'elle
lui actuellement qu'il a financé le
département pour un million d'euros et
je pourrais multiplier la rénovation de
verlaine également donc bien sûr que
nous aidons les bailleurs à rénover mais
ce n'est pas ça qui fait qu'un bailleur
ne remplace pas d un chauffage pendant
des mois ou laissent des moisissures
s'installer dans le logement ça c'est
pas une question d'argent c'est une
question d'avoir un bailleur qui jouent
le jeu et c'est là où il faut durcir le
ton et c'est le mois où j'assume de dire
que nous travaillerons plus avec des
bailleurs qui ne donne pas à leurs
locataires la jouissance paisible de
leur logement c'est à dire leur bon
droit parce qu'il en va de la dignité
aussi d'un certain nombre de trappistes
patrick lang enfin
j'entends bien mais la seule solution
d'après vous c'est quand même de
continuer à financer ces grands mots ces
grands bailleurs ses promoteurs et c'est
au même titre que on parlerait de
l'emploi c'est exactement pareil quand
on écoute explique qu'il faut financer
les entreprises pour qu'elles
fonctionnent pour qu'elles embauchent
etc et ont continué à déverser du pognon
dans les grandes entreprises parce que
les bailleurs c'est pas des petits c'est
pas des petits la 26 semaines et c'est
pas des petits des petites épiceries du
coin bon mais oui mais ça ça ne marche
pas parce que ça ça fait vingt ans ça
fait 30 ans que la situation elle se
dégrade de ce point de vue là parce que
le problème du logement c'est pas
uniquement un problème de condition de
vie c'est aussi un problème de loyer
c'est aussi un problème de salaires
c'est un problème de salaires et bien
évidemment les salaires aujourd'hui ils
sont trop ils sont trop bas pour pouvoir
se loger et il ya toute une partie de la
population qui est obligé d'aller de
plus en plus loin pour pouvoir pour
pouvoir se payer un logement parce qu'on
discute du transport on discute du
logement etc mais tous ces problèmes ils
sont liés principalement à 7 à ce
système capitaliste qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui il ya quand même un
certain nombre de grands groupes
industriels et financiers qui
s'enrichissent de manière éhontée et qui
laisse toute une partie de la population
sur le carreau et le logement on ne
pourra pas le régler né à trappes nés
ailleurs sans s'attaquer directement aux
tenants de la finance si vous souhaitez
réagir encore sur ce sujet sinon va
changer de thématiques juste un dernier
mot à mot très rapide on a aussi un
sujet sur la transparence dans les
attributions de logements il n'est pas
normal que des gens tentent des années
sans devoir d'explication sont
comprendre pourquoi leurs dossiers ne
reçoit aucune proposition on a besoin de
ce dialogue on a besoin d'eux d'accorder
des rendez vous que les élus tiennent
des permanences et puisse expliquer
pourquoi un dossier est en souffrance et
pas simplement un renouvellement tous
les ans sans qu'on ne voit jamais le
bout du tunnel on a besoin d'eux mais de
la transparence et moi je vais proposer
d'anonymiser les demandes de logement
comme cela se fait dans d'autres
municipalités ça permettrait d'écarter
toute cette défiance sur ce sujet du
logement parce qu'il ya trop de familles
effectivement qui attendent depuis trop
longtemps dans des conditions difficiles
autre sujet qui va nous intéresser à
présent c'est la question de la sécurité
c'est une des thématiques qui revient
souvent au niveau national on le voit
déjà dans la précampagne présidentielle
de 2022 au niveau local déjà comment
agir contre la petite délinquance et
contre les problématiques plus grave les
situations plus importante encore vous
avez à chacun des propositions selon vos
sensibilités bien sûr on va débuter avec
vous patrick planque on va voir les
temps de paroles qui s'affichent et
c'est vous qui est train avec un petit
peu plus de retard pour vous le constat
il va au delà de la problématique de
sécurité il ya une vraie misère
matérielle et donc forcément une
délinquance oui bah bien sûr parce que
ça ne peut pas ça va ensemble
voilà ce que ce que je constate c'est
que et dans les discussions et dans
cette campagne et
le premier thème de sécurité c'est quand
même pour la population c'est quand même
la peur de perdre son boulot la peur que
son fils ou sa fille n'est plus
d'allocations chômage qui va pas qui va
l'empêcher de payer la crèche de payer
les loyers et de payer les factures à la
fin du mois c'est ça la vraie insécurité
alors bien évidemment
il ya de la délinquance il ya mais
toute la société part à vau l'eau comme
on dit il ya toute la société à
l'échelle de la planète qui est en train
de quêter à feu et à sang il ya des
milliers de gens qui sont déplacés il ya
des guerres sur la moitié de la planète
et puis d'un autre côté il ya eu un
débordement de fric éhontée avec des
gens qui en dépensant qui envoie là y
compris d'ailleurs de manière un les
dernières les dernières publications on
voit quand même c'est eux combien
onze mille milliards de 11 milliards de
fraude fiscale bon bien évidemment plus
la société elle fonctionnera de manière
anarchique avec la seule idée qu'on
défend c'est de dire oui il faut le
chacun pour soi l'individualisme écraser
les autres etc et bien sûr qu'on aura on
aura de la délinquance on aura des
problèmes dans les quartiers on aura des
tas de choses et l'idée que moi j'ai
envie de défendre c'est une idée
justement de contraire une idée
d'organisation une idée de quand on fait
référence au fait que dans tous les
quartiers dans toutes les usines dans
tous les ateliers il devait y avoir des
militants qui organise les choses oui
j'appelle de mauvais aussi de recréer un
parti pour ça parce que justement ça
conforterait c1 organiserait un peu la
riposte y compris d'ailleurs contre la
petite délinquance qui se nourrit de de
toute cette de toute cette société qui
qui part dans tous les sens et et la
déliquescence de la société en général
mais concrètement à mai et rap quelle
structure vous mettriez en place pour
justement ça puisse s'organiser à et
répondre aussi aux inquiétudes des
citoyens qui voient les infos que tout
autour de voir des problématiques plus
grave aussi on va pas le résumer à ça
mais la radicalisation aussi ça rentre
aussi dans ce domaine là et et comment
vous interviendrez comme comme pour les
autres sujets en se faisant le relais de
un certain nombre d' un certain nombre
de remarques d'un certain nombre de
quartiers de gens etc et puis en
organisant parce que moi je pense
sincèrement que l'organisation
collective c'est plus fort que
l'individualisme qui qui génère la
délinquance et qui dégénère les
problèmes aujourd'hui qu'on peut
rencontrer dans les quartiers ou dans
dans tout un endroit et bien sûr que
aujourd'hui la seule réponse à la
sécurité qu'on peut qu'on nous apporte
c'est il faudrait aligner des caméras et
des la police mais tout ça c'est du
c'est de la fumisterie c'est pas parce
qu'on aligne des des policiers dans les
quartiers qu'on arrive à régler le
problème c'est pas bien sûr que ça se
règle pas comme ça othman je vous passe
la parole peut être honoré pour sa
patrie plan qu'est ce que la police
répondrait à tous et est ce que au delà
de ça et effectivement il faudrait
parler des mesures d'accompagnement je
relisais quelques-unes vos propositions
il ya les policiers municipaux il ya la
vidéoprotection et puis à la mise en
relation des jeunes des parents des
forces de l'ordre si un travail commun
et une implication des citoyens moi
j'assume pleinement de vouloir assurer
la sécurité la tranquillité des
trappistes à 100% ça ne veut pas dire
que ça va tout régler la police
municipale mais c'est une partie de la
solution une partie est en toute chose
il faut être équilibré et ne pas
considérer qu'aujourd'hui on a besoin
d'une police municipale 24 heures sur 24
7 jours sur 7 parce que c'est
aujourd'hui cette police là qui fait le
travail de police de proximité qu'on le
veuille ou non puisque la police
nationale est concentré sur d'autres
missions ce n'est pas la police
nationale qui s'occupe du stationnement
des incivilités des nuisances des
occupations de halls d'immeubles c'est
ainsi et donc nous avons besoin d'une
police municipale 24 heures sur 24 7
jours sur 7 là aussi on est nombreux
désormais à lire c'est que cette idée
progresse
malheureusement en un an les effectifs
ont été divisés par 2 nous avions huit
policiers municipaux l'été dernier nous
en avons plus que quatre aujourd'hui et
donc moi j'assume de vouloir renforcer
les effectifs de police municipale d'une
police qui soit évidemment respectueuse
dans la proximité avec les habitants qui
se déplacent quand les habitants
l'appellent qui ne ferme pas à 17 heures
et qui assure 90 recettes une trentaine
d'agents vous souhaite rien mais trop
souvent de la taille
de la ville de trappes c'est une
trentaine d'agencés ce que nous avons
dans toutes les villes comparables elle
encourt ils sont 32 à montigny ils sont
un peu plus de 32 ils sont 34 pour être
précis donc on a cet effectif là c'est à
peu près un agent pour 1000 habitants
c'est comme ça que ça fonctionne dans
beaucoup de villes désormais et nous
avons besoin de le faire et je veux
préciser aussi que ça ne coûtera
quasiment rien aux trappistes puisqu'une
bonne partie de cette dépense peut être
prise en charge par la région nous ne
faisons dans le cas de 300 communes
différentes en ile de france et nous
l'avons reçu malheureusement aucun
dossier de la ville de trappes je le
regrette à double titre vous pouvez le
comprendre cette année et donc nous
pouvons financer une bonne partie du
coût de cette police municipale et
encore une fois je le dis ça n'est pas
du tout sécuritaire c'est tout
simplement du concret parce que nous
avons besoin de cette présence policière
de terrain dans le respect encore une
fois et surtout pour améliorer le cadre
de vie des habitants et dans le dialogue
y compris avec la jeunesse qui n'est pas
du tout contrairement à ce qu'on le
pense hostiles à la police par principe
simplement l'appropriation de l'uniforme
c'est aussi un sujet nous avons besoin
de cette police municipale et ce sera
vraiment une de mes priorités il ya plus
de dialogue aujourd'hui entre la
population les forces de l'ordre par
exemple que dans vos propositions il y
avait aussi la mise en place de ces
médiateurs sociaux d'une prévention
spécialisée luc miserait faudrait
impliquer le citoyen
absolument ce que je voudrais dire quand
même c'est que l'essentiel des missions
sont enfin dépendent de la police
nationale s'il ya eu abandon de la
police de proximité
monsieur nassourou c'est bien à qui on
le doit donc un moment donné on a besoin
d'une police nationale qui
je le dis tranquillement soient plus
nombreuses mieux formés et qui répondent
à tous les enjeux dans une ville comme
la nôtre où par exemple il ya beaucoup
trop de racisme de violence eh bien il
faut répondre à ces enjeux là
on a besoin d'eux
de rectifier le tir par rapport à ça la
police municipale ne peut pas être le
substitut
c'est une fois de plus l'état qui se
désengage donc on a besoin de cela et
puis on a besoin surtout effectivement
comme vous l'avait soulevée dans nos
propositions et ça rejoint ce que je
disais tout à l'heure par rapport à la
revitalisation des quartiers est de la
ville on a besoin surtout d'une présence
humaine beaucoup plus importante mais ça
rejoint un peu ce que tu disais tout à
l'heure sur le lien social
avec le monde associatif qui
interviennent beaucoup plus avec des
médiateurs sociaux qui soit beaucoup
plus nombreux et j'espère qu'il y aura
des crédits à la région pour développer
le nombre de médiateurs sociaux qu'il y
aura beaucoup plus de crédit au niveau
du département pour la prévention
spécialisée parce qu'aujourd'hui on est
extrêmement loin du compte et donc
toutes ces mesures là
permettrait que la tranquillité publique
soit un petit peu mieux
assuré
si vous souhaitez répondre tous ces
outils évidemment concours tous du même
objectif il faut pas opposer la police
municipale au médiateur aux éducateurs
etc au contraire on a besoin de tous ces
outils ont aussi besoin de caméras de
vidéoprotection notamment aux abords des
commerces et aux abords des
établissements scolaires on a besoin de
tout cela et donc moi je n'oppose pas si
différents moyens mais je constate que
c'est sur la police municipale
aujourd'hui qu'il ya un manque et qu'il
ya un retour en arrière donc c'est pour
ça que j'insiste là dessus mais bien sûr
qu'on a besoin d'un accompagnement
humain bien sûr qu'on a besoin
d'éducation simplement si on parle de
tous les thèmes à chaque fois on va pas
y arriver et moi je veux juste prendre
un exemple sur l'accompagnement humain
ça commence d'ailleurs dès l'école ce
thème n'a pas prévu d'en parler en tant
que tel mais sur l'éducation c'est pas
normal aujourd'hui de ne pas avoir une à
une atsem par classe qu'on a besoin de
cet accompagnement là et donc c'était
évidemment très important mais ça ne
remplace pas cette police municipale
parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est d'échelon qui
manque beaucoup à trappes pour des
sujets encore une fois du quotidien pas
pour mettre simplement des pv de
stationnement en zone bleue mais
vraiment pour assurer un cadre de vie
paisible apaisé et y compris d'ailleurs
la police municipale fait de la
médiation parfois est compris entre
voisins donc on a besoin c'est une
manière aussi pour une collectivité
d'avoir aussi de la présence humaine sur
le terrain aujourd'hui on entend
beaucoup parler trappe comme un
territoires perdus de la république
c'est ce qui est revenu très très
fréquemment encore dans les discussions
et tous les articles qui ont fleuri dans
les médias nationaux ces derniers mois
sur cette campagne municipale avaient
tous la même toile de fond
radicalisation sécurité territoires
perdus quand on dépeint votre ville la
ville dont vous souhaitez être le maire
chacun de vous trois de cette manière
vous dit que il ya encore beaucoup de
choses à faire quelle serait votre
priorité dans ce domaine là patrick
planque
je suis atterré de voir cette cette
campagne est d'ailleurs les gens avec
qui on discute ils apprennent parce que
c'est très très loin de ses très très
loin de leurs préoccupations
je reviens sur les thèmes importants
mais mais oui aujourd'hui avoir un
salaire correct qui permet de vivre
dignement ne pas être obligé de quitter
de quitter son domicile 14 heures 15
heures 16 heures par jour et penser que
c'est normal d'avoir deux heures de
transport pour aller bosser 8h et de
revenir et et taper la gare jusqu'à
jusqu'à le bout de trappes parce qu'il
n'y a pas de bus bon voilà c'est ça la
priorité des gens alors effectivement
ils sont touchés quand on dit dans la
presse quand on dit dans les journaux
trapé est une ville perdue et c'est
parce qu'ils le sentent voilà mes mais
la vraie préoccupation est le vrai
levier sur lequel il faudrait taper cetc
c'est bien sûr pour que les conditions
de vie elle s'améliore et pour ça on
passera pas par des promesses on passera
pas par quoi que ce soit qui peut
l'aider mesure est la seule solution
c'est que les travailleurs s'organise ça
veut dire qu'il va falloir arracher pied
à pied les villes à vis des bailleurs
vis-à-vis des propriétaires vis-à-vis
des grandes entreprises pour que les
salaires et augmente pour que les
conditions de vie s'améliorent et quand
on voit aujourd'hui on n'a pas discuté
du logement mais on a discuté du
logement mais sur le transport on a
voilà je voulais juste de saluer quand
même les grévistes de transdev qui sont
en grève depuis quatre semaines
aujourd'hui un contre les attaques de
leurs de leur direction contre les
attaques de la région qui veut diminuer
dégrader leurs conditions de boulot
dégrader leurs conditions de travail et
pour le coup la région n'y est pour rien
dans le cadre explique de très bien sûr
été sage aussi mais bien sûr bien tous
les styles sont évidentes ils y sont
qu'ils y sont au même titre que la sncf
que la ratp etc et la région et bien
évidemment ils ont ils ont raison de se
mettre en grève parce que c'est ça la
solution pour rentrer chez elle répond
qu'on vienne à ma question sur ma
question premières et aux menaces que
vous a répondu aussi concernant
spécifiquement la question de la région
luc miserait territoires perdus trappe
je vais avoir votre sentiment vous qui
vous présenter à la municipalité de
trappes quand vous entendez ces mots là
mais ça ça
cccc la phobie médiatique c'est fin
c'est u c'est une catastrophe les gens
qui utilisent ces choses-là d'abord
visite met pas les pieds ou alors ils
traversent trappe trappe c'est une ville
de lons date de ça fait des décennies
oui c'est une ville où il ya énormément
de solidarité bien sûr que elle est
touchée par la montée de
l'individualisme par les difficultés la
précarité la pauvreté que patrick
planque évoqué tout tout de suite et
forcément ça a des incidences c'est loin
d'être un territoire perdu
si on considère ça que ceux qui disent
ça ils se taisent et puis qu'ils
rentrent chez eux
nous si on est là c'est parce qu'on
pense que précisément c'est pas un
territoire perdu et qui a énormément de
choses à faire un au titre à trappes à
gauche c'est dynamisons traps et
intelligence il ya énormément
d'intelligence dans cette ville qui sont
en sommeil comment on agit pour créer
des clips pour faire en sorte que ces
intelligences émergent qu'elle se
concrétise dans les faits donc on a un
potentiel énorme on a d'énormes
difficultés mais on a aussi d'énormes
atouts un sujet qu'on a pas parlé on a
une gare de triage
mais c'est mais ce sont des centaines
d'emplois si elle était réactivée alors
bien sûr ça peut pas se faire au mieux à
l'échelon de la ville puisque ça à
l'échelon national eh bien nous ce qu'on
propose à trappes à gauche c'est qu'on
crée un réseau des villes où il ya les
gares de triage pour faire pression sur
un gouvernement qui dit qu'il faut
augmenter le fret marchandises mais
qu'il ne le fait pas parce que ça c'est
la diminution de la pollution
atmosphérique
c'est la fluidité c'est tout un tas de
problèmes qui sont évités
il ya moyen en
développant ce rassemblant à tous les
niveaux bien sûr au niveau local mais
aussi avec d'autres instances donc ce
territoire est loin d'être perdue la
gare de triage à la ferme et à la ferme
et quand elle a fermé son gouvernement
hollande moi j'ai interpellé le ministre
benoît hamon à l'époque à des voeux en
lui signifiant que ça allait fermer
parce que les cheminots mon avait alerté
il s'est tourné vers mme sur ab pour lui
dire alité au courant à lire à berre
regarder le bout de ses chaussures il
n'était pas au courant
c'est eux qui ont fermé ça et
aujourd'hui viennent de donner des
leçons c'est impossible c'est impossible
donc on a énormément je cite ça c'est un
exemple mais parmi tellement document
vous et deux dents pour conclure ensuite
2 des développements de cette ville on a
énormément d'atouts on a énormément de
difficulté mon a aussi énormément
d'atouts simplement il faut libérer sa
voix présent sur cette question de
territoire perdu vous aussi vous êtes
maire demain votre priorité bien sûr que
nous avons un sujet sur améliorer
l'image de la ville ça demande un
travail sérieux travail est là aussi
apaisée de
communiquer intelligemment dans la
maîtrise et en même temps en cassant
toutes ces images tous ces clichés qui
nous sont constamment renvoyer et moi je
veux dire extrêmement clairement je
n'accepte pas qu'on dise que trap est
une ville perdue
c'est une ville quand on dira que moi
madame à qui j'ai consacré là ça fait
dix ans que je suis engagé ça fait dix
ans que j'y suis c'est une ville que
j'aime c'est une ville qui m'a permis de
me lancer d'ailleurs en tant que élus
prg à 26 ans pour la première fois en
2014 c'était après la fin de ma vie que
je veux c'est de la politique me fait un
bon résultat ça m'a donné envie de
continuer et donc je ne laisserai jamais
personne dire que trap est une ville
perdue simplement il y a des choses
qu'on peut améliorer c'est une réalité
que de le dire je pense à la
diversification des commerces qui est
une attente de beaucoup de trac piste
aujourd'hui pour que précisément ce
vivre ensemble fonctionne pour qu'il y
ait de la mixité mais ceux qui jouent de
cette image et qui nourrissent parfois
des réflexes de repli de haine de
division c'est ça aujourd'hui qu'il met
aussi à l'image de trappes moi je le dis
très clairement pour tous ceux qui
connaissent trappe c'est une ville
extrêmement attachante c'est une vie de
prière à laquelle on a envie de se
consacrer et je crois que ce sont pas
m'aimer mes contradicteurs ici qu'ils
vont dire le contraire et donc il faut
qu'on le défende ensemble l'image de la
ville vous savez au moment où il ya eu
l'épisode du professeur de philosophie
mon colistier mon acolyte mustapha
larbaoui a écrit ali rabais en lui
proposant qu'on travaille ensemble et
qu'on l'ait peut-être un moment un
discours commun sur l'image de la ville
nous n'avons jamais reçu de réponse à ce
message et je le regrette parce que
c'est précisément pour cela
qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes avec mustapha
larbaoui avec guy malandain dans le
rassemblement parce que nous considérons
qu améliorer l'image de la ville elle
passe par un rassemblement de ce type là
nous arrivons la fin de ce débat du
premier tour nous allons prendre une
fois de plus les enregistrements de vos
listes en préfecture pour les
conclusions vous êtes libre du terme que
vous avez dû des thèmes pardon que vous
allez aborder mais vous n'avez que me
une minute trente patrick plan qu'on va
donc débuter avec vous en une minute
trente votre votre conclusion
moi j'appelle donc les travailleurs avec
ou sans emploi actifs ou à la retraite à
se saisir de cette élection pour faire
entendre leur colère salaires et
pensions bloqué alors que les prix
augmentent le chômage augmentation des
cadences de travail tout cela c'est
inacceptable les grands de france les
grandes fortunes les profits
capitalistes s'accumulent à un pôle
tandis que nous avons de plus en plus de
mal à joindre les deux bouts il n'y a
pas de raison d'accepter cette situation
la liste que je conduis est constituée
de travailleurs de tous âges et de tous
secteurs voté pour cette liste c'est
affirmer que nous les travailleurs nous
n'avons pas à continuer à subir la
dictature de la rentabilité capitaliste
s'est affermie que nous devons nous
battre pour nos intérêts l'augmentation
des salaires la répartition du travail
entre tous l'embouchure les secteurs
utiles à la population les hôpitaux les
transports un changement de la couleur
politique ou pas à la mairie de trappes
ne changera pas nos conditions de vie ce
qui améliorera nos vies c'est de prendre
conscience de nos intérêts et de notre
force c'est de nous organiser pour nous
préparer à nous défendre et à défendre
notre peau dans nos mobilisations dans
le conseil municipal et militant ouvrier
communiste révolutionnaire serait les
yeux et les oreilles des travailleurs de
la commune y compris ceux qui n'ont pas
le droit de vote sous prétexte qu'ils
n'ont pas la nationalité car c'est nous
tous qui faisons tourner la société qui
prône ils ont toutes les richesses
affirmer que
nous sommes pas résignés ni à
l'exploitation ni au capitalisme et
votez pour faire entendre le camp des
travailleurs
nomades masos et avoue union
républicaine pour trappe c'est le nom de
votre ville votre conclusion à une
minute moi je veux adresser à tous les
trappistes qui nous regardent un message
d'apaisement de confiance leur dire que
demain s'ils nous font confiance
naturellement ils auront une gestion
voulait dit sereine rassembleuse qui ne
va pas préférer une partie de la ville à
une autre qui ne va pas opposer les
trappistes selon leur origine selon leur
leur âge qui ne va pas opposer les
jeunes aux seniors nous avons besoin de
tout le monde et moi ce qui m'intéresse
ce n'est pas la sensibilité politique
des trappistes ce n'est pas de savoir
d'où ils viennent c'est simplement on
travaille tous ensemble pour donner aux
trappistes le meilleur cadre de vie
celui qu'il mérite parce que ils
méritent mieux que ce qu'ils ont
aujourd'hui parce que je crois que la
ville peut aller dans une meilleure
direction c'est pour cela que ce
rassemblement était composé avec
mustapha larfaoui avec guy malandain
nous avons besoin de rassemblement nous
avons besoin de sérieux nous avons
besoin de résultats concrets et je veux
leur dire que tout cela nous le feront
je l'espère rapidement dans la confiance
dans la sérénité dans le changement
parce qu'il va falloir qu'il y ait des
dossiers importants qu'ils soient repris
en main mais en même temps dans un vrai
souci de respect pour chacune et pour
chacun d'entre vous le cul miserait
trappe à gauche pour votre liste on vous
écoute une minute également
écoutez nous on pense qu'il faudrait que
les trappistes reprennent confiance en
eux mêmes et pour ça ils peuvent compter
sur nous notre liste est composée de
gens qui sont sur trappe depuis des
dizaines d'années qui travaillons avec
les trappistes depuis des dizaines
d'années je suis à l'image de cela je
suis arrivé à trappes en 1983 comme
instituteur au service de la population
j'ai travaillé dans le monde associatif
notamment dans le club de football mais
aussi dans les associations caritatives
mais aussi à l'association culturelle de
trappes donc nous
les habitants de trappes savent qu'ils
peuvent avoir confiance en nous parce
qu'on a déjà travaillé avec eux nous on
n'est pas venu à trappes pour se faire
élire pour avoir une notoriété on est
venu à trappes au service et pas pour se
servir de cette ville parce qu'à la fois
on me dit qu'elle a une image le
territoire perdu mais en même temps elle
attise bien des convoitises donc
pour nous c'est le message qui a un
potentiel et on le sait parce que on a
travaillé encore une fois énormément
avec cette population on veut sortir par
le haut merci beaucoup à tous les trois
d'avoir participé à ce débat du premier
tour élections municipales donc attrape
ce dimanche à 10 octobre à bientôt sur
tv 78
[Musique]